Alright guys so in this video we are going to talk about risk management, this is one
of the most important things when it comes to becoming a profitable trader.
I've seen a lot of people, I've seen a lot of people mess this part up because they think
that strategy, your trading strategy is the only thing that's going to make you successful.
But in reality, psychology and risk management are one of the most important things when
it comes to trading.
So usually one of the biggest mistakes that I've seen people like is that they use different
lot sizes or different risk person for each trade.
So what they would do is they would risk one person for a trade and you know, the other
trade that they're going to take, they're going to risk two person, right?
And then the other trade, they're going to risk 0.5% and when they take another trade,
they're going to risk, I don't know, 2.5%.
Now that is a wrong approach to trading and risk management.
You should only be using one risk per each trade.
I don't care, right?
What you say?
I just want to see you use, if you're using one person, keep on using one person for each
and every trade, okay?
I do not want to see you use 2% for some trade or 0.5% for trade.
I mean, if you're using 0.5% for every trade, then go ahead and use 0.5% for every trade.
But if you are using 2% just simply use 2% for every trade.
Now you should never go up to like 2% personally because that is just risking so much guys,
especially when you are taking profit from challenges.
This is not the way to go for it.
If you have your personal funds, you can go up to 2% per trade, but it's just personal
preference and how much you are willing to risk, so just stick to 1% per trade or 1 specific
percentage that you're going to use for each and every single trade.
Because what happens is let's assume that you use 1% for 1 trade, right?
And you win it, so you have you are 1% in profit overall.
So the next trade, the right next trade, you take 2% use 2% in a trade and then unfortunately
you lose that trade.
So now you are in negative 1 balance.
However, if you use only 1%, you would be at break even, okay?
So that is something that you must know and must practice, I mean not practice, but you
should know that you have to only use one certain percentage for each and every single
trade that you are going to take, right?
If you mess up the numbers, even if you have a good win rate, you want to profitable.
So now here's the thing, right?
Let me do this.
Now a lot of people think that the strategy, the best strategy in the world is going to
make you win 80% of the time or 90% of the time.
The thing is, even if the strategy is good, you're going to have a losing period.
You can lose up to 6 trades in a row and I mean it, okay?
Even ICT says that in his videos that he used to lose 8 trades in a row, right?
But it didn't affect him because he knew that his strategy was profitable in the long
term, in the long term, right?
So what happens with a lot of people is that they lose 4 or 5 trades in a row and they
just stop using that strategy.
I know it's really frustrating to lose 4 or 5 or even 6 trades in a row.
Even I lose 6 or 7 trades in a row.
I actually did lose in the month of August.
It was the worst month for my trading, but I was so profitable, but I lost 6 or 7 trades
in a row and that was terrible for my feelings, but you know, I knew my strategy is profitable
and I kept on following the rules like a robot.
So what I would suggest is when you lose like 3 or 4 trades in a row, you reduce your risk.
So let's assume that you were using 1% risk, right?
And you lose 4 or 5 trades in a row.
Now this only applies to your personal funds and not from challenges because for profit
from challenges, I recommend that you only risk 1% because you have like 30 days, right?
So it's not wise to use 0.5% risk per trade.
For problems, just keep on using 1% risk per trade.
However, for personal funds, right?
If you lose like 4 or 5 trades in a row, you want to drop down to using 0.5% risk.
And you know, eventually if you still lose like 4 more trades in a row, you drop down
your risk to 0.25%.
And now just listen to me, okay?
Just hear me out.
If you keep on using 1%, right, for 8 trades that you lost, you lost 8%, right?
You lost minus 8% off your total portfolio.
But if you switched back to 0.5% after losing like 4 trades, right?
So let's assume you lost 4 trades, you are a negative 4%.
Right?
Let me do less.
4%, whoops, minus 4%.
You lost, right?
And you lost 4 trades and now you're in down minus 4.
So when you switch back to 0.5% and you lose, you know, 4 more trades, that's actually minus
6% drawdown.
So you are basically saving your account at this point, right?
Because every single strategy can have a losing period.
I don't care who tells you that you can win and have a profitable week every single time.
No.
You can ask every single profitable trader and ask them, are you profitable every single
day, every single week, every single month?
The answer will be no, because we are, you know, fed these thoughts that trading is going
to instantly make you rich.
Of course it can, but it requires a lot of psychology, right?
And it also requires a very solid risk management.
And this is what I'm teaching you, right?
So if you lose like four or five trades in a row, you switch back to 0.5% if you were
using one person before.
Now if you lose 12 trades and that is very unlikely with my trading strategies, you can
lose up to five, six trades in a row.
That's normal.
But if few, let's say, if you lose like 12 trades, right?
And you were using one person, you lost 12% right?
So our rule is that after four trades, after losing four trades in a row, we reduce our
risk size, right?
So we lost four trades, we reduced the risk to 0.5%, right?
And we lost four more trades, so reduced our risk person to 0.25%, right?
So let me do the maths here.
So we lost 12% by using the same person, right?
And we lost 12 trades.
That is negative 12% in your portfolio.
However, after, you know, four trades, you switch back to 0.5% and you lost eight trades.
That is how much, six percent, right?
So now when you are lost, you have lost six percent, right?
So that is, oh my God, guys, my maths is really wrong.
I mean, you get the gist of it, right?
You know what I'm talking about.
You want to keep on reducing your risk and when you, when you, you know, so when you
have lost 12 trades and you are using smaller risk.
So let's assume that you win four trades, right?
In a row.
And this is just for example, and you're going to just know what I'm talking about.
So you win four trades in a row using 0.25.
So when you person, so when you win four trades in a row using 0.25 after eight losses in
a row, when you win four trades in a row, when using 0.25%, you switch back to using
0.5%, okay?
And when you win another four trades or you win trades and lose trades, that is equivalent
to the profit, you know, equity that you lost, then you can switch back to 0.1%, sorry,
1% only, right?
So when you recover your losses by using the same risk, then you can switch back up to
the 1% rule.
I hope you got what I was trying to explain in this risk management video.
So there is, I've seen people do this mistake.
So let's assume that there is, where is the box, oh my God, bro, okay, there you go.
So you have your PR, right?
And you get a solid entry at this level.
So let's assume that you bought here, right?
So now price is going up.
You see profits, wow, you are in profit, very nice.
You have your take profit level, let's assume here.
And you are holding your trade, holding your trade, and then what happens?
Price reverses and you lose the trade.
This is terrible risk management, okay?
So let me tell you how you can avoid this from happening.
So when you get your entry, look at the closest lower high or a high low.
So you can see this is a lower high, right?
When this structure is broken, you move your stop loss to break even, right?
That is a simple rule that you must follow because you do not want to, you know, keep
your trade risky.
You want to go risk-free when price breaks some sort of structure.
And when that happens, when price breaks this structure, you can either take some profits,
right?
You can take some of the profits off the trade, right?
Like, I don't know, like 20% or 25% just so you lock in some profits, okay?
My rule of thumb is that when you hit one to two risk to reward, you can close up to
40% or even 70% off your trade and let the rest running.
But that's what you up to you.
So when the structure breaks, you maybe take some profits or the alternative is when price,
you know, breaks the structure, what you can do is instead of going break even, you
can move your stop loss below this high low.
So you are essentially trailing your stop loss.
So you are locking in profits when the trade is going up.
So with the trade going up, you keep on locking in some profits.
So there are two ways to approach this.
One you can take partials along the way when structures break or you can trail your stop
loss, right?
Like this below every single higher high low, right?
So you get, you know, another higher high, you move your stop loss here, right?
And then you move your stop loss here and let's assume you move your stop loss here.
And then what happens is price reverses.
So you get the full locked in profit, right?
However, if you took partials, the rule of thumb would be, you know, marking out some
POIs.
So this was the first POI, right?
So this structure broke, we move our stop loss to break even and we take partials.
So let's assume there is some supply zone or fair value gap here, right?
So when price comes into this level, you maybe take 20% off the table as well, off
the trade as well.
So price retraces and then you will have your final TP level and then you will have...
So you can take like two partials, okay?
You don't want to take more than two percent because it's going to decrease your actual
profit factor.
So make sure you only have like three.
The third one is your final TP, right?
So you have one partial take here, you have your second partial take here and then you
have your final TP here.
So that is how we roll with this.
I don't know if there's more to it, but yeah.
So now let's talk about psychology.
Now this is one of the most important things that you should know, okay?
And it's like if your psychology is not strong, if your mind is not strong, you are going
to fail regardless of your trading strategy and your risk management.
Now psychology is very important because as a human, we have the nature to take revenge
or seek revenge if something bad happens to us, right?
So let's assume that you as a beginner or a lot of people do this mistake is when they
lose one trade, what they would do is without looking for a new setup, what they would do
is they would randomly enter at a random place at a random time just to revenge trade, just
to gain back the money that they have lost with that one single trade.
What happens?
You lose another trade.
So now you have lost two trades in a row and your mind is just heated, okay?
It's just want to destroy the whole world.
So what you are going to do is going to increase the risk person days, right?
So previously you were using one person per trade, you lost two trades in a row, you lost
two person.
So what you would do is you would use three person this time just to, I don't recover
those losses.
And what happens, again, you lose that trade.
So now this is absolutely the worst way to trade, okay?
And I know I have done that as well when I was a beginner and a lot of people that I
know have done that as well and you guys must have done that as well.
And there are some things to improve your psychology, okay?
So I will give you some tips and maybe you can apply them and it's going to help you
a lot.
So the very first rule of thumb is that you want to train yourself to only take two maximum
two trades per day, no more than that, okay?
So even if the good rule of thumb is to only take one trade per day, if you can do that,
trust me, your psychology is going to be very strong next month, okay?
In a month, I could say.
So you take one trade a day, you lose, you go back home, enjoy the rest of the day.
You come back the next day, you win a trade, very nice.
So now when you win a trade, you just quit and come back the next day.
When you come back the next day, what is going to happen is you are going to be in a good
mood, right?
And you're going to be excited and you're going to have a good mood and that is really
important for trading, okay?
So that is going to help you a lot.
So try taking only one trade per day.
That is the best way to go to go for.
The other rule is that you can maybe take two trades per day, okay?
Or what you can do is that you can take three trades and if you lose one trade in a day,
you just quit.
But if you win one trade, you can take another trade, right?
And then you lose a trade, you quit the day.
But if you win one trade and you win the second trade as well, you can go for a third trade.
And if you lose that, you quit and you end your day in profit.
So now how do you even do this because that saying this is easy, right?
I can tell you to do this, but the psychology is really such an important thing that is
not easy, but if you follow the rules that I'm going to tell you, you can actually increase
your psychology.
So a lot of people might call me dumb for this, but how I improve my psychology is through
meditation.
Now meditation is something that you can search up on YouTube is basically focusing
on one thing and sitting and breathing and bringing out.
So meditation or what it does is just, it just freshens up your brain, it freshens
up your body.
And what you can do is you can learn meditation on YouTube.
I cannot teach you how to meditate because it's a little complex thing, but essentially
what is it is that you sit near a very quiet, sit around a very quiet place, right?
And you meditate for 20 minutes and what is meditation is that you relax and free up
your mind for 20 minutes a day or 10 minutes a day if you're a beginner, free up your mind
and focus on breathing.
Okay.
So meditation is actually focusing on one single thing at the time.
So what you do is that you breathe in and then breathe out and you focus solely on
that breath.
You remove all the thoughts from your brain.
You do not care about training.
You do not care about your family.
Just leave everything behind and focus only on your breathing.
Okay.
There are a lot of ways to meditate.
You can search them up on YouTube.
There's actually this one guy by the name Hamza.
You can search up on YouTube, Hamza meditation and the video is going to pop up and you can
watch that video.
It's really helpful and I know it sounds really dumb, but it's actually what helped me improve
my psychology.
It helped me increase my brain productivity.
So the other thing is that along with meditation, you want to have a proper sleep schedule.
You cannot be sleeping at a random time, like 3 AM, 4 AM.
No, you want to wake up at a decent time, which would be 8 or 7 AM in the morning, right?
You exercise, exercise is really important as well for your brain.
And now these are the tips that you must include in training because for training, you need
to be mentally strong and how you get mentally strong is through meditation, you know, exercise
and gratitude.
Now, what is gratitude?
Even if you lose a trade, you can be grateful for that trade because it was a lesson for
you.
Okay?
Instead of, you know, raging over that loss trade, you could say that, wow, I'm thankful
for this trade.
It has taught me something, right?
You lost the trade, you find, you try to find out the reason why you lost that trade.
You search and you should be grateful because eventually you are just paying a small little
fees for some sort of information.
So that is a win-win for you.
So you meditate, you exercise at least 15 minutes a day, guys.
That is easy, right?
And then you show gratitude towards your life.
You could say, I'm grateful for my family, I'm grateful for the food that I had today.
You could say, I'm grateful for literally anything that makes you a little bit happy
in some sort of way, right?
You just, you could just show gratitude.
Trust me, this works amazingly and I'm not just spitting bullshit at the moment.
Okay, I'm telling you actual facts and truths that has helped me increase my brain power.
So you can meditate, you know, exercise, show gratitude towards small things.
That doesn't matter what it is, but if it's, you know, shows you some sort of, it gives
you some sort of happiness in any way, even if it doesn't give you an happiness and you
just want to show like a gratitude towards a thing.
For example, I look at the moon sometimes and I say, wow, I'm grateful that the moon
exists literally.
And what it does is it eases up your brain and it gives you like this easeness in your
body that if you even lose trades, it doesn't matter because when you are coming into trading,
right, there's a simple rule that if you cannot afford to lose what you are investing, then
do not come into trading.
Because if you are investing your little lifetime savings into trading, guys, there are no guarantees
that the markets are going to stay the same.
All right, I'm saying this right now.
I don't know what's going to happen in the upcoming five years, but the thing is just
believe in yourself, stay calm when trading, okay, follow your rules, like a robot, okay.
Just stick with and try these things out guys.
I mean it, meditate, exercise, gratitude, right?
It's going to really help you.
So one thing is that if you lose like three trades, right, in a week or two trades in
a week, you just come back the next week, because what can happen sometimes is during
a specific week, there could be a lot of news, right?
And that could be the reason why you're losing trades.
So just avoid that week and just come back the next week, right?
It really depends on you if you want to keep on trading for that week, but the thing is
a good rule of thumb if you are a beginner, if you lose one or two or three trades in
a week and you are a negative, then just quit and come back the next week.
So I really hope that you guys enjoyed this video.
That was one of my most important videos that I've made.
So make sure that you follow this thing.
You want to show gratitude towards small things every single day, right?
And one thing that you should do is you should journal your trades, okay?
You should journal why I lost the straight.
You could say, I took this trade at this time, right?
I used this strategy.
I used this trade.
I traded during London session.
Was there any news?
How big was the displacement for market structure shift by measuring the pips, right?
And by journaling, you can become even a better trader than me because the thing is, guys,
even if I give you my, if you want to give you like the, you know, what I said, the best
strategy in the world, you can become a better trader than me because it really depends on
backtesting and generally.
So you can journal like this and just look and just, you know, add in the wind rate and
all which work, which time works the best, which session works the best, how much displacement
is valid for market structure shift and all and it's going to help you with your psychology
as well because you're going to be confident in your trading system.
So I hope you guys enjoyed this lecture and I'll see you guys in the next video.